Traduttore: SILVIA ALLONE
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Io vi parlo di DNA,
e vi faccio dei disegni;
ho preferito questo
alle cose tecnologiche,
molto avanzate dei miei colleghi.
Il DNA è questo, una doppia elica
che è all'interno delle vostre cellule,
miliardi di cellule;
e che costituisce la base dell'umanità,
c'è tutto là dentro:
tecnologia, etica, medicina, arte,
costruzione - guai, anche, un sacco.
Malattia, sofferenza,
l'uomo che dobbiamo sempre tentare
di rimettere in mezzo
a questi salti tecnologici,
che sono spesso vissuti
come assenza, distruzione,
assenza di sviluppo, inquinamento,
distruzione della presenza
dell'uomo, dell'umanità;
ma vorrei mostrarvi, anche,
tutti i lati positivi,
di questa tecnologia,
che può essere giusto il contrario
di quello che pensate.
Per farvi capire quello che faccio
è necessario farvi
qualche disegno di biologia semplice.
Dunque, a me servono tre cose
per mettere a punto questa tecnologia:
dei virus, di cui voi conoscete
un esempio molto particolare,
che è quello del virus dell'AIDS,
che dà una malattia mortale nell'uomo,
per cui non si conoscono, ancora,
terapie definitive.
Poi c'è una cellula,
che contiene il DNA nel nucleo
ed è una cellula malata.
Perché questa cellula è malata.
Ci sono quattro caratteri che contengono
tutte le informazioni di questo libro.
Sono quattro: A,T,C,G.
Basta che una di queste lettere
sia stata scritta male
e tutto un organismo, un organo,
un sistema non funziona più.
Tutto lo sforzo
che noi facciamo, in medicina,
per queste malattie
geneticamente stabilite,
è tentare di retrocorreggere
questo errore,
come se avessimo una macchina da scrivere
e potessimo cancellare questo errore
e rimettere il carattere sano.
Nel 1990 -
mi sembra di parlare come le vostre nonne,
nel 1944, la guerra mondiale -
i virologi ci hanno dato
delle informazioni importantissime,
ci hanno detto cosa c'era
dentro questi virus
e perché questi virus potevano andare
dall'esterno all'interno della cellula
e integrarsi nei cromosomi dell'uomo.
Questa è la caratteristica principale
del virus che produce l'AIDS,
l'immunodeficienza umana.
Milioni di persone sono affette
da questa malattia nel mondo,
milioni di persone
con una prognosi a corto termine
molto pericolosa
in Africa e in molte altre regioni.
Quando abbiamo saputo,
quando i virologi ci hanno insegnato
come è fatto questo virus,
cosa trasporta come informazione,
perché è piccolissimo,
noi ci siamo detti -
noi, non io personalmente,
io ho rubato delle idee
che venivano da campi diversi
e le ho giusto messe insieme
per la costruzione
di un nuovo trattamento -
ci siamo detti:
questi elementi ridotti al minimo,
che voi non vedete, che ci infettano,
li possiamo demolire biologicamente
e farne giusto dei trasportatori,
dei treni, come delle navette spaziali.
Uno dei primi oratori ha detto
come possiamo andare dalla Terra a Marte;
a me fa solo spavento,
ma forse voi avete il mio stesso spavento
all'idea di andare su Marte.
Vi provoco la stessa paura
nel dire che uso questo
come un trasportatore,
come un treno, un aereo,
una navetta spaziale;
e lì posso mettere dentro
tutta l'informazione genetica che voglio:
non proprio tutta, ma almeno quella
in cui la natura si è sbagliata;
e gliene rimetto una copia normale,
in modo che questo virus abbia perso
tutte le sue capacità di replicazione,
di produzione della malattia,
di [uso] della cellula ai suoi fini
e gli do, come istruzione,
di portare un'informazione genetica
all'interno della cellula.
Quindi quello che faccio
è una cosa, così a pensarci,
estremamente semplice.
Prendo le cellule dell'individuo,
questo è il soggetto malato,
non so neanche disegnare,
questo è il mio massimo
questo può essere un adulto
o un bambino malato,
e prelevo le cellule malate,
queste qua, le porto in laboratorio
e in laboratorio le metto insieme
a questi elementi minimi che sono i virus,
che hanno perso tutte
le loro capacità biologiche,
sono utilizzati solo
come navette spaziali.
Ho tenuto, delle loro proprietà,
solo la loro capacità di andare nel nucleo
e nel nucleo vanno
a depositare nei cromosomi,
in un posto quasi qualsiasi,
l'informazione genetica
che manca a queste cellule.
Siccome queste sono
le cellule del paziente,
e quindi non sono le cellule
di un donatore completamente
diverso da lui,
io le posso ritrapiantare
a questo soggetto
e sperare [che guarisca]
della sua malattia.
Questo è quello che abbiamo fatto
alla fine degli anni Novanta:
esattamente,
il primo ragazzino con questa malattia
è stato curato nel 1999.
Perché vi ho detto, non c'è solo medicina:
c'è sofferenza, c'è etica,
perché la prima malattia
alla quale ci siamo attaccati
è una malattia mortale,
i bambini nascono
senza difese immunitarie.
Tutti qua dentro sapete
che cosa sono i globuli bianchi,
queste cellule che passano,
come una specie di esercito,
a proteggervi da tutti gli agenti,
da tutti i microbi che trovano in giro
nell'aria che respirate,
nelle ferite che avete,
nel bacio che vi scambiate
con quello malato che vi sta vicino.
E questi bambini, invece, nascono
con nessuna cellula,
nessun globulo bianco,
muoiono nelle prime settimane
che seguono la nascita,
se non sono curati.
E ci siamo detti:
se noi correggiamo subito,
appena nati, queste cellule,
forse abbiamo una speranza
al di fuori di una prognosi impossibile;
e nel 2000, effettivamente,
abbiamo potuto rendere noto
il fatto che questi bambini,
condannati a vivere
per il tempo che si può
dentro delle bolle di plastica,
delle stanze protette, in aria filtrata -
nessuno li può toccare, vedere, baciare -
potevano uscire all'aperto
con un sistema immunitario
completamente riformato.
Ma, vi ho detto prima,
la medicina non avanza così:
sfortunatamente, ho già avuto la fortuna,
ed ho ancora la fortuna,
di vivere un periodo
che posso chiamare
una specie di rivoluzione medica,
rispetto alla medicina
che mi hanno insegnato tanti anni fa,
30 anni fa a Padova;
ma quello che abbiamo scoperto
è che due di questi bambini,
qualche anno dopo,
hanno sviluppato una complicazione
di questa malattia,
perché i virus si erano messi
vicino a delle informazioni
genetiche pericolosissime
ed hanno prodotto una proliferazione
non controllata di queste cellule,
sotto forma di una specie di cancro
delle cellule dei globuli bianchi
di cui forse avete sentito parlare,
che si chiama leucemia.
C'è stato un oratore,
prima di me, che ha detto:
I ragazzi, quando sono in questi campi,
dove imparano a costruire
delle macchine, degli utensili,
dove si servono della loro testa
e delle loro mani contemporaneamente,
imparano più dai guai che combinano
che dagli oggetti finiti che producono.
È quello che è successo anche a noi.
Nel 2000 ci siamo fermati:
e nello stesso tempo,
la tecnologia aveva dato nel mondo
la conoscenza di tutto il genoma umano
e quindi siamo riusciti a capire,
in un tempo brevissimo,
con l'aiuto della comunità internazionale,
dove questi virus erano andati
a conficcarsi nelle cellule,
perché avevano sregolato
in un modo così catastrofico
la vita di queste cellule;
e siamo ritornati in laboratorio,
abbiamo di nuovo cambiato i virus.
Abbiamo tolto tutte queste parti
che erano più pericolose
per la proliferazione,
il controllo della vita di un organismo,
e siamo ritornati in clinica
qualche anno dopo,
dopo anni di ricerche, nel 2006,
e ci siamo attaccati
ad altre malattie genetiche,
a questa, alla prima
che è stata un modello
per tutta la medicina dell'epoca,
perché finalmente
avevamo prodotto la prova
che potevamo correggere il genoma
in modo definitivo.
Questi ragazzi hanno, oggi, 16, 15 anni
e sono il gruppo, diciamo, più vecchio
dei bambini trattati
per terapia genetica nel mondo.
E quando vengono in ambulatorio mi dicono:
"Ma perché devo continuare
a venire, sto bene,
lei mi rompe un po' le scatole
a farmi venire"
e non si rendono neanche conto
che dobbiamo continuare a seguirli
perché non sappiamo cosa succederà,
domani, a queste cellule.
Dal 2006 ad oggi,
con il cambiamento
di questi
aerei nucleari
che arrivano nel cuore delle cellule
a riportare l'informazione
genetica corretta,
abbiamo corretto tre deficit immunitari,
una malattia neurodegenerativa
del sistema nervoso centrale
e una malattia del globulo rosso.
Tutti in Italia,
e soprattutto in questa regione -
sapete che c'era una malattia
che si chiamava talassemia,
una malattia del globulo rosso,
bambini anemici che devono essere trasfusi
tutti i trent'anni
I flussi migratori, le migrazioni
delle persone, i viaggi, gli aerei,
hanno fatto sì che un'altra anemia,
molto simile a questa,
che in Italia si chiama
anemia falciforme o drepanocitosi,
è diventata la malattia genetica
più frequente nel mondo.
Milioni di bambini, uomini e donne,
sono affetti da questa malattia nel mondo.
L'OMS l'ha dichiarata causa mondiale,
perché tra qualche anno
non ci saranno più trasfusioni,
non ci sarà più la possibilità
di trapiantare tutti questi pazienti.
La terapia genetica è attesa
come un modo per venire a capo
di queste milioni di persone
che muoiono costantemente in Africa.
La grande maggioranza di questi bambini
muore prima di raggiungere
il quinto anno di vita,
perché non ci sono trasfusioni,
perché hanno la malaria
nello stesso tempo.
Quello che mi ha insegnato
questo progresso della medicina
è una cosa che è molto legata
alla tecnologia,
un po' come Mister Wireless:
più la tecnologia diventa complessa,
diventa semplice trasportarla
e diventa semplice portarla dappertutto,
più diventa personalizzata la medicina
e meno, diciamo, una medicina a caso
che tra gli altri effetti ha quello
di sollevare i sintomi di una malattia;
più è [economica] per la società.
La terapia genetica, oggi,
è fatta paziente per paziente,
quasi che faccia un menù personalizzato
per ogni bambino,
per ogni adulto che tratto,
ma domani questa è la terapia
che costerà meno alla società,
perché la potremo fare in ambulatorio,
perché possiamo trasportarla,
perché quello che dobbiamo trasportare
è molto poco, e tecnologicamente
trasmissibile con molta velocità,
un po' come il suo wireless,
dappertutto nel mondo.
Quello che trovo un po' peccato
è che andiamo più veloci
dei nostri amministratori politici,
dei governi, del pensiero economico,
perché il pensiero economico è ristretto,
vede solo oggi, domani
e non vede tra cinque o tra dieci anni
cosa succederà alle terapie convenzionali,
che costo avranno nella società;
e non riescono ad investire
altri soldi in questi trattamenti,
che invece domani costeranno molto poco,
permetteranno un'uguaglianza
della distribuzione della sanità
ad un numero molto
più importante di persone,
permetteranno che noi andiamo
con questa tecnologia,
che sia insegnata ed applicata
a della gente che vive
migliaia di chilometri lontano da qua,
che forse non ha acqua,
che non ha il trapianto,
che non ha l'unità di cura intensiva,
di fare - di accedere
a delle terapie innovanti a basso costo
e con una preparazione
che è molto meno importante
di quella che le cosiddette
"terapie convenzionali" hanno.
Con questo volevo dirvi che la tecnologia
non è solo distruzione dell'ambiente;
non è polluzione esclusivamente
la tecnologia è crescita,
è sviluppo per tutti,
basta che sappiamo portarla
e distribuirla, in tempo idoneo,
su tutta la superficie della Terra.
L'altra cosa molto importante
che ho sentito, e alla quale
vorrei agganciarmi,
è quella dell'arte.
Simona ha detto che la danza è quella cosa
che mi avvicina più all'amore.
Io vi dico: non c'è un'attività umana
che vi separa dall'amore
o dai sentimenti, dall'etica:
qualsiasi cosa fate,
qualsiasi persona volete diventare,
c'è sempre posto per la creazione,
per l'arte, per la libertà,
per trasportare qualcosa di importante
altrove, velocemente, in poco tempo.
L'altra cosa importante
è quella che ha detto Lorella, la scuola.
Il solo punto dove tutti
possiamo diventare uguali,
gli uni agli altri,
è la scuola, i banchi di scuola,
questa scuola che sta diventando
sempre più povera, maldistribuita,
dove le disuguaglianze
sono sempre più forti.
Quindi se oggi ho un messaggio
da lasciare ai giovani e ai meno giovani,
a quelli che hanno preso
il tempo di venire qua:
malgrado la tecnologia,
malgrado i film, malgrado l'audiovisione,
noi abbiamo bisogno di incontrarci,
perché solo incontrandoci
possiamo avere idee, creazione,
trasporto di informazioni;
e quindi nessuna tecnologia
eviterà il fatto
che dobbiamo vederci,
dobbiamo ispirarci mutualmente,
dobbiamo cogliere da voi
quello che noi non sappiamo fare.
Wireless in Africa
vuol dire avvertire in tempo reale
donne incinte drepanocitarie
che devono prendere
l'ossigeno per sopravvivere,
gli smartphone non servono solo
per i vostri SMS,
possiamo connettere persone
nei posti più disparati del mondo
e mandargli un messaggio,
a seconda del livello,
dove sono nella loro gravidanza,
per avvertirli di fare un'azione
che salverà la loro vita in tempo reale.
Questa è tecnologia.
E se con questi 15 minuti
ho convinto uno o due ragazze,
sedute tra di voi, a fare Medicina,
credo che questo sia stato
il mio più grosso contributo
allo sviluppo nel mondo.
Grazie.
(Applauso)